Allah.
[Silence]
I shall
I sh
to
I
[Silence]
alone. Oh
my
god.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Muslim
in Allah. for
[Silence]
Wasam.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says in the opening verses of surah al
the chapter
of the prophets
and it gets its namesake
because of the unique list of prophets
and their very unique yet very cookie
cutter story.
Each of the prophets and messengers
they have a very unique people that they
are sent to. They are very unique in
themselves.
Yet we see that their message is exactly
the same.
And the general framework
of their message is the same. Exactly.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions as a
prelude to these stories.
He says subhanahu wa ta'ala speaking and
addressing the prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii Wasam
and we have never sent a messenger
before you
except that our revelation to him.
the gist of his message,
his prerogative,
what he has to deliver to his people
that his legislation and message
revolves around.
None is rightfully worshiped but I so
worship me.
And our prophet sallall.aii Wasam
has said,
he says, "The best thing that I have
ever said, me and all of the prophets
that have preceded me, is none is
rightfully worshiped but Allah.
This kima,
this statement
though brief in its actual words
is extremely vast in its meanings. As a
matter of fact,
all of the Quran is an explanation
and an expression of this statement.
as
has famously mentioned
that all of the Quran is about
all of it. Every story, every ruling,
every person who is mentioned in the
Quran,
it is all expounding
and detailing and fleshing out the
meanings,
the dimensions, the dynamics
of
none is rightfully worshiped but Allah.
Oh, this is what it translates to. It
does not just mean that there is only
one creator or that there's only one
God.
This is something that the majority of
humanity has always believed in. This is
something that human beings believe in
from the moment that they are born and
able to conceptualize their inner
monologue.
They understand somewhere intrinsically
by the fra that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has created into them that there
is only one God that I am a creation
that I am the result of the will of that
creator
that I
am reporting to a higher power than
myself.
Every human being understands this at
from the time they are born.
However, this becomes corrupted and
distorted by the adults in a child's
life.
Anytime a child
starts to say or believe something
contrary to this pure and very basic
message, it is not the result of that
child's
default
disposition.
This is a result of the adults in that
child's life distorting that child's
futra.
And we see that all of the people that
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
sent to
the people of Quraysh
from the most disbelieving amongst them
Abu Lahab and Abu Jah and others. They
all believed in the existence of Allah.
Not only did they believe that Allah
existed, but they worshiped Allah and
they believed in Ibraim and they
believed in the legacy of Ism
and they believe that they were chosen
from amongst the Arabs to be the
custodians of Allah's house, the Ka. And
how could they not believe in Allah?
Being that by the time the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was born
and by the time he was sent as a
messenger to them, many of them were
alive and had witnessed
the incident of the elephants of Abraham
when they attempted to demolish the Kaa.
the army from Yemen that came to try to
destroy the ka and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala defended his house.
As a matter of fact, if you read the
story of
the Arabs when this happened, when
this occurred and this army with a group
of elephants, it said nine elephants or
more or less had come
to demolish the Kaa and Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala mentions this in
that when Abra was on the outskirts of
Mecca
and on his way to destroy the Kaa,
what ended up happening is he called for
the chieftains of Bish.
and one that came out to meet him. He
said, "All I ask of you is to just spare
my spare my sheep, my flock of sheep."
He said, "I'm about to destroy your
cattle and you're worried about your
sheep." He said, "I
am the master of my sheep, so I have to
look out for them. And this Kaa has a
master. I'm not worried about the Kaa.
The master of this Kaa will look out for
it. And so it was. They believed in
Allah. Of course they believed in Allah.
They believed that he existed. They
believed that he was worthy of worship.
And indeed they did worship him.
However,
their belief was corrupted
by a mixture and a kind of medley
of
distorted ideas that were introduced
to them over time and compounded.
They believe that
you know Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
very great
and we are very lowly and sinful
but there are men amongst us that are
very righteous
and we are too unclean
to go to Allah directly.
So what they believed is that when
righteous men or saints from amongst
them would die, they would construct
a
an an omage
in the liking of this individual.
And this is the history of
and manad.
These were all the names of saints that
they believed were very close to Allah.
And just as a king, every king has
advisors that if you want to get a
message to the king, you don't go to the
king directly. You go to those who are
close to him and they put a good word in
for you. Likewise is their belief with
Allah.
That we are too unclean and unfit to go
directly to Allah. So what do we do? we
go to his saints,
the men and women that are very close to
him.
And so they would do offerings to these
saints.
They would slaughter for these saints.
They would pray to these saints. They
would make offerings to these saints
because in their mind they believe that
these saints would then
start to them. they get on the
saints good side and then they will be
you know the saints will put in a good
word for them with Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala it's not that they didn't
believe Allah didn't exist or that he w
he was somehow unworthy of worship it
was not that they didn't worship Allah
indeed they very much worshiped Allah
but the problem was and where the rubber
really meets the code
and where the difference between the
believer and disbeliever came down to
was worshiping Allah alone without any
partners. This is where they differed
with the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
and not just OUR PROPHET BUT EVERY
people before
they differed and fought against their
own prophets because of the issue of
worship.
They believed in Allah but they could
not accept the implications of
of worshiping Allah alone without any
partners of worshiping Allah alone
without any partners and worshiping him
only in the way that his prophet and
messenger Muhammad teaches suiam.
This is where they could not accept.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
regarding the previous nations, all of
the people of every messenger and
especially
the Jews and the Christians. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala and every
nation before
was but commanded
to worship Allah
making sincere to Allah all of their
deeds
in obedience to their prophets in
obedience to their respective prophets.
This is what the message of every
prophet and messenger ever was. And this
is what Allah Subhanahu Waaala says in
this verse which we opened with.
And we have never sent a messenger
before you, oh Muhammad. Oh messenger of
mine, except that the message, the gist
of that message,
what that message revolved around that
was sent to every messenger
was none is rightfully worshiped, but I
so worship me. Worship me alone without
any partners. This is what every prophet
was sent with. Our prophet Muhammad
sallall.aii Wasam says in an erration
collected by both Bkari and Muslim
on the authority of
he says
[Silence]
we the prophets
we are paternal brothers.
Now if we look at this this example
this analogy that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam gives what is
what are paternal brothers?
Well they're brothers that have
different mothers and share a common
father. That's a paternal those are
paternal brothers.
Now here the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam says we the prophets are
paternal brothers. He then explains what
he means by this. He says
our mothers differ meaning our books are
different
our laws are different.
The resources that we were given are
different. They differ with respect to
the time and place in which they were
sent. But our religion is one.
He says our mothers differ yet our
religion is one. What is that religion?
The religion of
the religion of none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah.
[Silence]
ill.
Be happy.
[Silence]
and and
quite literally translates to none is
rightfully worshiped but Allah because
the word
it is what the name of Allah is actually
taken from Allah
in the Arabic language is a very unique
word and a very unique name but this
word Allah
originally
was El
meaning the one who is worshiped out of
love and exaltation.
But because they use the word so much,
it's constantly being used by people.
Elah
the Hamza in the middle of the word el
it's a little bit it's a little bit
heavy on the tongue. It's kind of
disrupts the flow of a person's
sentence. And so
we dropped the hems to make it easier to
say, to make it roll off the tongue more
naturally.
And those lambs were merged together and
it became three lambs, Allah.
And this is where the name of Allah
comes from. The meaning of Allah is the
one who is worshiped subhanahu wa
ta'ala. And this is THE CHIEF OF ALL OF
HIS names
because this is the most
proprietary
of his descriptions with respect to the
to humanity.
And so he is Allah. He is the one who is
worshiped out of love and exaltation.
And as he describes himself,
This is the message that all the
prophets came with. Our prophet Samkari
he said
the analogy of my message
and how it fits in with the rest of all
of the
messages of the prophets that came
before me.
is that of a mason who built a
beautiful castle or a beautiful
building.
And he left one spot where there was a
missing stone, a missing brick.
And people would come and
go around this beautiful building and
they would admire it and they were all
stricken by its beauty and precision.
But then they would come upon the part
that was missing the brick and they
would say if only the mason would lay
this last brick.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam
said, "I am that last brick and there is
no prophet after me." Sallam.
Every single one of the prophets and
messengers, they were an iteration
to the same
masid, the same house of Allah. They
were all acting as a brick
that was culminating in the same house
of worship of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
And so our prophet was no different than
the rest of the prophets in that sense.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells him say
to them I am not an innovation
added something that is something that
is foreign to the rest of the prophets
and messengers that were sent before me.
We were all sent with the same message.
different rules for different times in
different places. But we were all
building and working towards the
construction of the same temple, the
same house of worship of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
do why do we
all
[Silence]
All
feed him.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
I shall.
[Silence]
Stand shouldertosh shoulder. Take this
time to ensure that your phones are
silent. Take this time to ensure that
your feet and ankles and shoulders are
in line with the feet and shoulder and
ankles of your two neighbors on either
side of you. With each person, make sure
that they are as in line with the two
people on either side of them. The row
will naturally be straight.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
whatever. So be happy with
Allah.
[Silence]
Allah
itself.
Hello.
The long
act.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
for him.
must be
[Silence]
equally
Amen.
[Silence]
Allah
Oh,
kebab.
Allah
[Arabic recitation]
Brothers and sisters, alaykum
gratitude
and thanks to Allah subhana wa t'ala.
I'm announcing that brother nan is back
from his sbatical leave.
Please greet him on the way out and also
there are some sweets by the door that
you could at least please enjoy. also
there is no Sunday program this weekend.
Donate generously on the way out.
[Silence]
Thank you. Thank you.